[Applause]
all right ross and drew everyone knows
that entertainment news waits for no one
a lot has happened since i last saw you
on monday so i'm going to quiz you
with the very latest pop culture
headlines let's see how much you know
okay
we did really well last time which makes
me even more nervous this time yeah i
don't want to brag but we were four for
four
yes you did you crushed it you crushed
it all right well now that you've laid
down the gauntlet let's get in it okay
all right
question number one of the pop culture
showdown what singer just made the huge
announcement
that she is expecting her first child is
it
ariana grande halsey or taylor swift
halsey wow you are on the money that's
right she's expecting her first child
halsey popped on instagram and she
didn't really announce that she just
said surprise holding her belly and that
means
i'm having a baby yeah we saw him yeah
yeah question number two what pop star
just tried their first
pole dance workout and posted it on
instagram is it megan italian miley
cyrus
or harry styles oh oh no
yeah i took i spoke way too soon uh i
don't know but my gut is going megan me
too is that what you're thinking all
right we're
totally guessing on this one lock us in
on megan
drew and ross you are absolutely right
it is meg the style oh my god
she is kicking off her two-week hottie
boot camp with a pole dance it's a
personal health and fitness journey for
her so you are right you're still you
still haven't missed a question okay two
for two okay
number three which music star just
snagged their first
leading role in a movie that requires
them to dress up
as an elderly person and blend in at a
nursing home
is it adele cardi b or justin bieber
uh i have i don't think adele right i
just don't i don't think so i think b
you're right okay i drew i'm with you
cardi b oh gosh
we're gonna go cardi b b you are right
again oh my god
bro i i can't believe this i can't
believe this
i can't believe cardi is starring in a
new movie called assisted living she's a
criminal hiding out from the police and
um
she dresses up as an elderly woman and
goes into a home
this is like sister act in an elderly
home i love you and i love her in
hustlers and i know she's interested in
acting and she's just so playful and
cool
my gut went to cardi b okay good
okay here we go what blockbuster rom-com
which grossed
93 million dollars worldwide turns
20 this year is it the wedding planner
how to lose a guy in 10 days ride
wars a would be the oldest of those
wouldn't you jennifer lopez
and matthew mcconaughey just did an ig
live so i say a
a you two just own the pop culture world
you're killing me
you're right again
you saw that instagram live where they
talked about their insta chemistry and
how hot it was
and the first kiss at the movie theater
where he turned to her
and they were just about to have their
first smooch because the scene required
it and he said to her
miss lopez i'm going to kiss you now
now look normally normally if you're if
you're
if you're a wife and you're sitting at
home and you watch your husband go on
instagram live and talk about his
instantaneous
um connection with another woman you'd
be a little worried
because it's jlo but he's married to
camilla alves she's like boy do your
thing
she's the most beautiful woman on the
planet camilla alves
and it's weird it's like when you go to
work
it's not as sexy as you would think on a
set where they're like literally like
you're you've got to go to the left we
can't see your face and you're just like
and there's a lot of people standing
around and you know some people are
bored
and not into it and you know it just
it's it's
it's hard almost to get lost in those
moments so
i think for people who know you're like
it's it's work i hit the best job
on the planet kissing matthew he's going
to say good job kissing a guy on a
pitching mound is pretty fun too right
i mean a pretty hot guy on a pitcher i'm
not gonna lie
i love my job when i get to kiss these
wonderful gentlemen
i i mean come on it's the hugh grant
adam sandler
like it's the it's the greatest job in
the world
am i the only male co-star you haven't
kissed
[Laughter]
yet it's early i mean
all right let's get can we sneak in
another one okay here we go yeah
for valentine's day rapper post malone
said he is giving
10 000 of these to frontline workers at
70 hospitals across
america is it weighted blankets pool
noodles
or crocs it's 100 c crock oh
drew are you sure said yes
because i used to be their brand
ambassador
and then he was the next one and he
still currently is i believe
are we right those crocs are red-hot
everybody in the world wants them they
are sold out but the front-line workers
will get them and drew once again
you are on the money and by the way
we here at et are still waiting for our
drew crocs we're just gonna all wear our
drew crocs one day okay so you
you all send them on over they're just
such a cool company they totally get it
and yeah post malone
and bieber they're all working with them
and
i'm really glad to see that post malone
is doing that because
i think he is so cool mm-hmm
yeah you guys own the pop culture world
what are these questions
away kevin let's do this again please
not just for game show week
are you in i am in forever i'm ready
i'll be back next week if you call me
okay
thank you so much catch kevin on
entertainment tonight
every weeknight obviously